pour Gérard Depardieu c'est le paradis
pour d'autres un concours très sérieux
pour moi aussi le Mondial du fromage
s'est ouvert hier à Tours Florent plus
de 800 fromages les meilleurs affinés de
longs mois dans des cas vous l’humidité
et même la composition de l'air contre
le résultat était à déguster aujourd'hui
au Parc Expo alors papa nous Aurélien
malheureusement mais par un jury
objectif et lire le meilleur fromager du
monde parmi 16 concurrents la Turquie
est allée pour nous sur place
sublimer sans en faire trop trancher
sans casser et surtout poser sans tout
faire s'effondrer le fromage c'est tout
un art 70 kg de matière première
d'exception pour concocter un plateau et
une sculpture sur le thème du fromage
dans les étoiles le tout en 4h
c'est de gérer le stress le temps et
puis de pas oublier qu'on doit mettre en
avant le fromage souvent on peut
vraiment se perdre à essayer de mettre
d'autres produits en avant de peut-être
tous c'est vraiment le fromage qu'il
faut mettre en avant là ils sont en
train de faire une épreuve qui dure 4
heures c'est quand même assez fatigant
avec la chaleur avec l'ambiance le
stress et du très très gros travail du
haut niveau dans ce concours mondial du
meilleur fromager il a lieu tous les
deux ans et cette année 16 candidats
s'affrontant final dont deux Français
la précédente édition c'est Virginie
Dubois d'Orne qu'il l'a remporté
maintenant elle siège du côté du jury
pour départager cette dernière épreuve
là on va regarder comment les candidats
travaillent on va voir s'il respecte le
thème on va voir si les fromages sont
mis en valeur si la filière est
respectée si voilà s'il y a des belles
coupes une propreté voilà en fait
vraiment le respect du fromage et de
celui qui l'a produit ah mais moi je
suis émerveillée d'année en année ça
monte de niveau je suis époustouflé en
fait
un concours qui prend place au Mondial
du fromage dans le parc des expositions
de Tours le salon est réservé aux
professionnels avec dans les allées plus
de 200 exposants dernier temps fort
mardi avec la finale du concours
produits c'est à dire l'élection de la
crème de la crème du fromage